how's your summer going Summer's
fantastic right now we got a time off
got a little time off we got a project
coming up later on in the summer which
I'm really excited about but in between
times spending time with the family yeah
going to go to Germany love Germany
where I'm going to the Dusseldorf okay
do you know it so I'm going because my
son is a footballer I have to call it a
footballer because it's actually soccer
here like European European footballer
right I like the accent everything going
on yeah it's a character like that yeah
but he um very thespian you thank you
yeah actually no thank you he he's going
to this camp in Germany so he gets to
play like International competition and
stuff it's a big deal this club soccer
thing is huge in Europe yeah what an
honor to get to play with them too
because it's just such a huge thing
culture it's massive way more so than
here which I grew up in soccer but no
one cared about soccer I grew up playing
soccer too but you play soccer until you
can play football like I played until I
played volleyball yeah you got it yeah
so is there any other I know one of your
senses into European football but your
other son is into something really cool
like he really is he's gotten into
fencing as that's really cool and very
Posh it's very Posh and he'll come up
and he'll like attack me he'll be like
on guard and he'll do his whole foot
thing yeah yeah he does this whole thing
I said bro keep it up this will get us
into college like fencing yeah is one of
those Niche things that every college is
like those places they're looking for
and I'm like fancy schools stick with it
yeah and what a cool thing like to
randomly want to do fencing like I just
that was never even an option when I was
growing up like you know what I'm saying
neither was it for me but isn't it cool
that you work your tail off though and
your kids get like this opportunity that
like we never have it's the best thing
yeah I would say like quick anecdote to
see your children pass you in anything
is always a great moment yeah my kids
play chess I play chess as well we're a
fancy ass family we try to be that
bougie black sort of thingamajig
but my kid my oldest will like come
close to beating me he hasn't beaten me
yet oh I love that you don't let them
win I don't understand
he gets that dub he knows he earned that
joint you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
but it's getting there oh that's gonna
be a really proud moment for you when he
kicks your butt and also like a tough
moment it should be both of them at the
same time I know I'm looking forward to
that for him personally
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]